i love doing shows like this so i cuz i
get to speak to
people who i've been watching uh for so
long in so many great movies
and doing such a great job of doing it
and he's part of uh
a new action-packed disaster thriller
that stars gerard butler
called greenland available on on demand
everywhere today the actor scott glenn
here on the rich eisen show how are you
sir
i'm good thanks for having me of course
thank you for
for coming on here on the show what was
your first gig
what was your first gig scott walk me
through that i'm talking about all right
my uh my first gig
was uh uh
understudying an off-broadway play
uh one of the many redos of zeus story
edward albee and i never went on stage i
was
i understudied the part and uh i
understand
both parts of two character play play
excuse me
and neither of them ever got sick so i
never went on stage
the first the first job that people
would probably
either might or might not know is the
first film i did
which was called the baby maker directed
by jim bridges who a few years later
directed me an
urban cowboy which kind of gave me my
life i've gave you
but uh before all that too uh apocalypse
now correct with francis ford coppola is
it is it true that
um you saved his life is that a fact
scott glenn well kind of ish
yes yeah we got
hit i got to the philippines to play a
small part in the
in in apocalypse and uh two days after i
got there we were hit with the worst
typhoon to have hit the philippines
since 1932.
it was called typhoon d-dang uh and
about two or three days
later uh
the way a horse mature works is you
can't just say oh we've
we've been trashed by our uh a typhoon
and we can't continue so you you've got
to give us your money
what happens is an insurance adjuster
has to show up and see that
in fact you're trying to shoot but can't
so the day that they were going to do
that was uh
a scene that was going to be you know it
was like a little brook
that it turned into a white water
because of the typhoon and
francis and the insurance adjuster and
the dp like four or five guys got this
boat to go
out onto this white water and they tied
a rope on the back of the boat
to i guess their idea was to pull the
boat
back to shore if it was the water was
too rough
and i saw what they were doing i was
maybe 50 yards away i saw what they were
doing
and realized that
the stream would take the boat right
downstream the rope would pull the back
of the boat down
the boat would sink and they would be
stuck swimming or drowning
or doing whatever you do in white water
right so when they let the boat
go you know i was fairly recently out of
the marine corps and always had a knife
on me
so i saw it happen i just instinctively
pulled out the knife and ran and cut the
rope and
you know later on that night francis
said you saved my life
and you know whether i did or not i
don't know it was just kind of an
instinctive move i kind of i cut a piece
of ropes all i did
okay so so you're saying colonel kurtz
wasn't the only one to maybe almost go
up the river
on that on that movie that's what you're
saying
yeah did you come across brando at any
point or you're you you just never did
i did indeed francis because of that
event
and i kind of helped out uh during the
you know getting ourselves together
after the typhoon
francis i'm a really great writer
and i owe you so let me write you a
better part than you came here to do
just
think of something you'd like to do and
we'll sit down and you know we'll
and we'll knock it off over the next two
or three days and i
said i want to be in the end of the
movie and he said scott i'm sorry that's
the only part of the film
i can't it's completely cast he said i
mean you could play captain colby the
guy that goes up the river ahead of
marty sheen
uh and you might have like one or two
lines but essentially you'll
you'll be like a glorified extra
and but if you want to do it i mean i'm
good to my word and i said yeah i do
because i i realized at that point you
know i was so
new to acting and it's probably
true of any kind of life and it's
probably true of what you do
you don't learn that stuff in the school
in the school
or from books or anything it's an
apprenticeship
and i wanted to be around marlon brando
and dennis hopper
and and just watch them work so yeah i
did i hung out with marlon
a lot um and learned a lot
what you got a good story can it's uh
safe for work
or scott you got anything for marlin
i've got a lot of stories but
you know he what i learned from marlin
was there are no rules sometimes he
would
make an expression in the mirror freeze
it
and say to francis okay start shooting
in other times he would come to the set
and wouldn't want to even see the script
who would just want to turn it all loose
and improv it
there's a scene in the film that never
made it to any of the many
final cuts of that film where i killed
dennis hopper
and i was trying to figure out different
ways of doing it and marlon came over to
me
and he said scott just remember this
just because they call it acting
doesn't mean you have to act why don't
you just drop the reins
a few times and see where the horse
takes you
and um he was he was a pretty amazing
guy
every dime he made on that movie he
uh spent rescuing a village that had
been trashed by the typhoon
um you know and then and then wouldn't
let publicity say anything about it
he was a pretty interesting guy scott
glenn here on the rich eisen show
uh for the right stuff uh did you meet
alan shepard
did you joe intentionally i did not
because it's i i i it's my experience
that when somebody knows you're gonna
explode their image onto a screen the
size of a four-story building even
without intending to they're going to
edit themselves
i never did this and i don't don't
believe this story and this is what i
did do
so no i i wanted to see
as much background stuff on by that i
mean
home movies talk to people that knew him
uh get as much information on
on on on alan shepard as possible
but i didn't really want to talk to him
uh i realized that that
in making that movie there there were
going to be two people playing the part
because they were going to cut back and
forth between
us you know the cast of the right stuff
and newsroom footage so
uh the exterior of shepard i i knew i
had to
have down the hardest part for me of
doing that part was being right-handed
because i'm very left-handed but anyway
when it was when the film was over he
he gave me the best review i i think
i've ever had
my favorite anyway what's that he sent a
letter sent a letter to phil kaufman he
said show this
to scott glenn in the letter he says uh
uh mr glenn you i just watched you play
me you you got you got it almost perfect
there's only one thing you missed and
that is you ain't
anywhere near as good looking as i am
is that right which was perfect i loved
it i mean
he didn't disappoint alan shepard all
the way through
oh my gosh scott glenn here on the rich
eisen show i literally could talk to you
about your movies all day let's move on
to the hunt for red october
what was it like uh on the set there
with with uh with connery and everyone
else what was it like there
for you on that one well it was uh
the research for that film was uh for me
a lot of fun
and uh developed a relationship with uh
i i got to go out on a fast attack sub
uh doing war games
that was the the captain of the sub was
uh
at the time captain tom fargo who later
became
admiral of the pacific and um
so i had that phenomenal experience and
while we were out on the boat i watched
the way that he dealt with his crew and
decided rather than
you know use whatever limited amount of
talent i have
i should just steal the whole
performance from him because he was
perfect
which i did sean was
sean had a reputation of being a rough
guy and and
some people thought he was hard to work
with i thought he was
i loved him and he at the end of that
film when
uh we played chicken with a russian
attack
sub yes uh that scene was
with sean c he comes back from his
shootout
in the engine room takes takes over the
sub
and does that scene and when we were
ready to shoot he said no this is scotch
scene
and uh the director
and the producers were on the set at the
time they said no no it's
uh why are you saying that and sean said
i was in the royal navy you don't give
command of your vessel to someone else
of equal rank
and get to take it back and uh he said
so
uh scott does this scene
and i was amazed
huh no kidding so that's how that came
about
and uh for you as a marine that had to
be
you know to be around uh that world had
to be something for you that you were
fascinated into all sorts of stuff like
that scott
yeah yeah i mean it's funny i mean yeah
i
i i was am and will be past the grave uh
as all marines are marine
but enlisted and uh
and i've only played officers which i
never was
nor did i want nor did i ever want to be
to tell you the truth
well again i guess that's what brando
said it's uh
just because it's uh acting you you
could just drop the reins a little bit
and see how it goes i got scott glenn
here
on the rich eisen show uh before we get
to greenland and and
uh i want to talk to you about a couple
other movies and then maybe a little bit
of sports before i let you go on your
day here
uh when you get the script for silence
of the lambs did you have any idea what
it would be what it would look like how
it would actually
hit the screen um and and
what was your thoughts when you get a
script from from jonathan
i'll tell you that they'll tell you the
truth when i i don't know
you know because it was a really well
written script but for whatever reason
i read it and
just didn't see it and through this
through
the script across the uh across the room
it bounced off the wall and uh my wife
was a
great artist she's a potter she walked
in and she said what's that and i said
that's something that
she said well who's gonna who's gonna
direct it i said jonathan demi
and carol said you better read this
again jonathan's a good friend of ours
he's a great director
so i did she was right i was wrong
but i didn't have any i don't think any
of us had any sense
that the film was going to be as
successful like commercially as it was
the second
highest grossing film of the year the
highest being
home alone and
i think that kind of blind in a good way
blindsided us all
because there it's there's so much
dialogue
that usually a film like that does well
where people speak english but doesn't
do well
in you know when it travels overseas
right and it was like number one film in
japan number one
and uh you know looking back on
it part of it is brilliant acting
not on my part but on jody foster's and
and and anthony hopkins but i think also
what makes one of the things that made
that film
work was you see a lot of films
about the the rites of passage of
boyhood to manhood i mean you see that
all the time
very rarely do you see a film where the
rights of passage are from girl hood
to becoming a woman and that's what
happens in silence of glory
well and then your character though
there was no sexual tension between your
character and jody foster's i think
helped that to be honest with you uh
scott you know like
that there was no that she was a
professional and that she was being
brought in to
to uh to figure out the mind of
hannibal lecter played by did anthony
hopkins blink
in the movie i don't think he blinked
once scott i don't think he blinked
once i i don't think so i don't think so
oh my gosh and then one last one for you
training day what what did you like
about that role and
and how you brought it uh and your
scenes uh with denzel
and ethan hawk or something else man uh
what about that well
thank you very much to begin with i try
i didn't want to i had work
pretty much no not pretty much
absolutely steadily for over two years
without having any time off
went from an offline broadway play to a
film in new zealand the shop for nine
months
to film the shop for four months in
germany coming back
stopped off in new york had lunch with
lassa hallstrom that turned out to be a
whole day and
he offered me a part in shipping news
and i had like
three weeks off be before having to
start
shipping news i get home here in idaho
where i am
and uh and i get an offer
from uh from warner brothers to do
um to do training day and i said no i
can't do it so denzel calls me up and he
said
this is the way it works scott i gotta
i have to have a best friend in this
film
who's a white guy who i'm going to kill
at the end of the film
and the whole audience including the
black audience
has to really pissed off at me for doing
it he said that's you
there is nobody
fire and become friends and he's i mean
dee is
absolutely one of the greatest actors
alive so anyway i said
you know i said denzel you know i don't
i
i'm going to touch you know i'm going to
hike up in the mountains and work out a
little bit
hang out with my wife before i go to
work again
and he said no you've got to do this
this is the way it's going to work it's
going to say
denzel washington ethan hawk in
training day and then right after that
it's going to say starring scott glenn
you only work five days and this is how
much money you're gonna
make and um
i said who made that deal dee said well
i
i kind of did and uh at the time they
were what they thought that there was
gonna be a writer's strike so
the studios wanted to get as much
inventory as possible
anyway i at that point
i read the script and essentially
saw two kind of amazing
monologues the second one of which ended
in denzel blowing me away with a shotgun
and um just went and did it
he's so much fun to work with and and
and
ethan is as well so we you know when
you're doing that kind of work it's all
not quite guilty enough to turn down
paycheck but it's almost like you're
just getting paid to have fun
scott glenn here on the rich eisen show
this is phenomenal so tell me about
greenland which is again available on
demand everywhere today
tell me about this one scott well i uh
i i read the script i got sent the
script who read it thought it was
really well written and uh
knew the direct i didn't know rick was
work really well but a little bit and i
there's a character a a real-life
character
whose last name is wah as well philly
and i wanted to talk to him to find out
if they were related if there was
you know if there was any way i could
sort of crawl into
you know the possibility of playing this
other character
and once i started talking to rick i was
just impressed with
the the way he saw the film which was
the way that you deal with an impending
disaster
is just by taking care of the people
close to you
to your family making sure they're whole
and well
and can survive with whatever's coming
down the road
so and you know he said in the part of
the film that i was going to be in
was what he said gave it its beating
heart
and uh and i love that you know what
the thing is with that movie that none
of us
could have figured out was that at the
time we made it
none of us had ever heard the term covet
19.
now you watch the film and you can't get
it out of your head
even though the disaster that's
that's kind of targeted us with covet is
slow moving as a well i don't know if
you call us low moving when you're
losing
3 000 people a day but at any rate
it's it the resonance of
what's going on in the world right now
with that film
just gives it up a kind of punch that
none of us could have
predicted and it's available on demand
everywhere today
uh before i let you go scott you got a
sports team favorite sport
you got oh what do you got born
and raised pittsburgh pennsylvania go
steal it uh-huh okay uh
and the last two the last two games have
not been
have not been joyful for me i'm gonna
have to tell you
you know i i i i'm just uh i'm
i'm hoping new orleans like kicks major
ass
and uh knocks and and i think and i
think
mike you know i mean i'm a fan but i
think that the steelers
offense is they got kind of beat up by
the
by a covet schedule and you know when
you've got young receivers
i think the greatest commodity is is
confidence is believing in yourself
right
and hopefully they'll get on paper
and playing playing to their
playing to their best numbers the
steelers have the best defense in the
nfl
i'll i'll stand solidly by that well i
gotta i gotta i think
i think you're nailing it in in this
fact scott um
that the the chiefs um the one
their their toughest opponent the rest
of the way is the one that's directly in
front of them in the new orleans saints
and then the steelers have a game
against the bengals on monday night
football this is your best
shot to get back into that one seed and
hold on to it the rest of the way this
week is
is pretty much where the rubber meets
the road for 2020 in terms of that
you're absolutely you're absolutely
right
but my feeling is you know and it's just
i mean i don't know if there is any more
you know crazy dedicated fans than a
steeler fan
but my sense is if they start playing
to their numbers and their ability and
they run into
and hopefully they run into kc
that uh mahone all of a sudden
realizes he's in a world he's never been
in
when minka picked him off and scores on
him twice
saxton so hard he can't remember what
his last name
is the right stuff minka fitzpatrick i
love it hey
scott glenn this was a i could not tell
you what a big fan of yours that i
am and this was a delight literally from
start to finish
i'd love to do this again whenever
you're you're up for it this was great
thank you
let's do it thank you thank you bet you
bet that's scott glenn
greenland available on demand everywhere
today
how great was that oh baby that was
great
pittsburgh's finest hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here